sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager once
bitmex the og crypto derivatives
platform and the best place to buy your
bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to another
episode of the lehigh plan show so this
month we have a brand new sponsor the
crypto exchange bit mech so a huge shout
out to bit max because without bit max
this wouldn't be able to happen so as of
may 17th they're actually launching a
brand new sport exchange to easily and
instantly buy and sell crypto so to
celebrate they're actually giving away
one million dollars in crypto to spot
traders over the next few months now
this is actually the biggest giveaway in
crypto so if you want to enter then i'm
gonna leave the link for you um in the
description below and it's gonna be
really exciting there's a huge range of
different assets that you can easily and
instantly buy so the description um will
contain all of the information and about
how to enter into that one million
dollar giveaway that's pretty amazing
so today we are going to have a very
interesting conversation and we are
always talking about controversial
things and which we're sort of not
allowed to speak about um but we have a
very interesting person who's going to
be joining me today so joining me is the
five-time world champion ufc mma fighter
it is jake shields jake welcome to the
show hey thank you how are you doing
i'm good thanks how are you
doing good like i said uh i slept in
woke up trying to get my [ __ ] together
real quick and wake up and do an
interview good well i appreciate you you
getting ready and you being here um
because there's so much that um i want
to speak to you about um
you've been very
vocal recently despite coming from you
know the mma ufc world um you've been
very vocal about issues that you see in
america so before we delve into that
can you tell everyone a little bit about
yourself for those who don't know who
you are from your mma career to your
most recent stance on free speech
government and i guess your fascination
with crypto
yeah well it's just um i mean for me you
know originally was a wrestler through
high school in college and then i got
sucked into the mma world through you
know i met um legendary chuck liddell
before he was famous and started
training with him and just uh
got completely addicted consumed my life
i'm for sure like you know most people
do something crazy like fighting or a
sport and that's all i wanted to do and
just train train train and uh everyone
told me i was crazy but then i seen
chuckled i'll start making money so i'm
like oh i can do it and so luckily uh
look i didn't listen to the haters you
know like you said went out there won
five world titles bought you know in the
largest crowd of all time versus george
st pierre had many uh
many memorable fights it's been a great
career at this point um not officially
retired but you know i me i may fight
again but mostly just training people
and investing and doing business and uh
which is you know you're in a crypto
which is something i need to get more
into i'm mostly invested in stocks but
now might be a good time to hop into
crypto
yeah now would be a great time the
market is down
now is the best time um but no i think
you know your career has been super
interesting um i've been following and
we spoke earlier and i was mentioning
that my brother is a huge ufc fan so as
a child he'd make me watch um so we're
going to delve into all that i do have a
lot of them questions about your career
but first i think what's really struck
me is how um you're sort of now taking
on um this weird culture that we have in
america right now um
so i guess my first question really is
if why do you feel as a fighter the need
to sort of move the fight in a different
direction and what would you say some of
the biggest problems are for you right
now in american society well a lot of
why i started speaking up i was living
in san francisco and stuff was just
getting so weird and i could see it but
then i would i would have conversations
with my friends and people would like
yeah i agree with you
i just can't say it because where i work
and this and i just kept hearing over
and over people agree with how i think
but they can't say it to me that was so
weird and uh i just never really used
twitter i'd had to twitter for probably
like 10 15 years but like my agents and
stuff would maybe tweet out for me i
never used it so i had the password so i
started you know
started tweeting out some of my opinions
originally not too good reaction i had a
lot of people were like you know angry
unfollowing me cussing me out i think i
started tweeting right during uh the
black lives matter riots and and so i
was like i was against the riots and
lockdowns which are two things that are
unpopular now but at the time the
lockdowns and people writing and luton
was extremely popular in america
which is kind of weird so i had a lot of
people angry at me but i'm like you know
what i need to start speaking my mind
and just uh
slowly did and then it was crazy i
originally had like no my phone was 100
fighting but now i feel like it's
probably more uh more politics stuff i
get more traction on the political stuff
than the fight stuff i tweet now
originally it was like no traction on
the political stuff but then slowly i
had people like um mike cernovich would
retweet me and i'll start picking up a
new audience i'll get like a big you
know a big guy like that would start
retweeting you're like oh you're picking
up followers that uh
you know i think how i do
but it was really interesting because um
when we were trying earlier you were
saying that you
were able to just say what you wanted to
say and you didn't get backlash in your
industry compared to other people for
example like artists musicians you know
they secretly feel certain ways and they
can't say it
yeah i was extremely fortunate i was
unsure when i started to speak my mind
like how are other fighters gonna feel
and then almost almost all of them were
on my side you know even with like uh
even with the black lives matter stuff
because there's really not there's
almost zero racism in fighting we're all
brothers on the mats and in the cage
it's one place where you see everyone
true to each other's 100 equals you know
we're guys you might talk [ __ ] to each
other but there's
i've never seen racism fighting i'm not
going to say it doesn't exist but it's
it's very small and you notice you
didn't see you know there's a couple
fighters that were black ice matter one
or two but it was not very many no
knilling and i respect the guys that did
wear it that we have respect for each
other but i think most of them realize
that it was more of a fake racial divide
than like a real racial divide in our
country
and even when it came to the lockdowns
how did the other fighters feel
almost exclusively were against it the
first couple weeks a lot of guys were
hiding outside i was trying to train on
the first week i was calling on my
friends and they're like oh we're
quarantining i'm like wait what
quarantining what the hell this
i'm not like the smartest person but i
looked at it i'm like we're not going to
shut down for two weeks and the virus is
going to go away when they shut it down
it was already in all 50 states you have
a virus in all 50 states and these
experts are sitting there telling me
that we can just sit there and it'll go
away
like you have to be an idiot not to look
at that and be like this isn't going to
happen that's when i realized i guess a
lot of people aren't that smart because
like i said i don't look at myself as a
genius but i could look at that and be
like this isn't going to work so i'm
just going to go out there and uh get
covered early and get it over with
i just i find it so fascinating when you
told me that your colleagues and other
fighters weren't that um bothered by
what you had to say and in fact agreed
it's sort of because like you know
fighting is all about taking
responsibility you're getting punched
all the time like you know you're sort
of used to not living in a sensitive
world i guess
yeah i know i said pretty much i was so
surprised all the fighters you too like
almost like almost all of them agree
with it it's like so few and the guys
that don't will still accept we're not
kind of we're not industry we're gonna
be like oh you don't agree with us we
hate you like you see on the other side
you know it's not like that but uh
yeah i think it's responsibility and the
reality you know
maybe anyone willing to get locked in a
cage with another man in front of like
thousands if not millions of people
watching
it's a pretty intense thing to do so
maybe it gives you a different
perspective on life
yeah i think i think that's it if you're
able to take a few uh well not a few
quite
many deadly punches then i think you can
sort of handle um you know
um
hateful words which keeps out your
feelings
i think things are fighting too like we
get hurt there in the cage but there's
also the amount of stress that goes in
there and the amount of like build up
the pressure because it's not like
you're just fighting you might get beat
up you're fighting in front of you know
sometimes millions of people sometimes
there's hundreds of thousands or
millions of dollars on the line if you
lose it could be uh there's just a lot
of pressure people learn to deal with i
think in regular life people aren't
dealing with those high pressure
situations and i guess fighters once you
get used to that you see the world a
little bit differently
yeah i mean you've been in so many
high-profile fights um becoming strike
force champion defending the
championship you fought gsp and the ufc
champions so how do you actually deal
with that pressure because you know when
you're the main event and you're the
last to walk out how do you keep calm
man it it's tough when you're the main
event if your main event on a big card
it's uh it's stressful ain't gonna lie
you have to just uh
you know stay as calm as you can i
always surrounded myself by really good
people that i was comfortable with and
laughing people you know a lot of times
before a fight we're sitting there an
hour before we're laughing cracking
jokes 30 minutes before we're getting
serious ready to kill but like i would
stay relaxed you see some of these young
fighters it's like they're three hours
out from their fight and they're yelling
and screaming and jumping up and down
it's like man you better uh you better
save that energy you're gonna need it
oh wow so how do you how do you deal
with it you just sort of have to
only
up to the bit where you walk out do you
sort of does that realization happen
it's a realization then yeah i honestly
try to like you you'll think about it at
night the scenarios and the fight and
stuff but i was trying to overthink it
and like you know a couple days before i
just try to like bury the fight like hey
you know i've done all my training i'm
just not gonna overthink all the bad
things that could happen you know and
when you do picture it picture the good
things always picture yourself winning
because you don't want to start getting
in your head well what if this happens
what if he kicks me in the face of this
would this guy has a good flying knee
what if what if he times that right you
start thinking about you have to think
about it a little bit of course so you
don't walk into those situations but i
think some guys are over dwelling in all
the negatives and it causes them not to
form their fight there's some fighters
that i've you know trained with who are
animals in the gym they get out there
and they just freeze up because they you
know they're overthinking everything
and you actually fought some monsters um
both in strikeforce and ufc like gsp
robbie lawler dan henderson tyrone
woodley so who was your hardest fight um
and why and why did they make it so
difficult
yeah man i've pretty much
fought all the best guys so it's really
hard to say you know who my hardest
fight is had a couple really tough ones
you know damian maya was a tough one
because he's a five-time jitsu world
champion and that's my specialty so we
were fighting each other in our same
specialties i think it hit much in that
fight but it was interesting someone who
had my level of jiu-jitsu because he was
literally the only other guy that you
know in fighting that had my level of
jitsu so that was interesting
overall pick one probably gsp because he
was just um he's so good at everything
he has no holes in his game he was a
true perfectionist and it's like uh you
know i fought him to a close fight but
it was just unable to uh to open up
those holes and you know i think i got a
good training camp for that fight i i
wasn't hurt i have no excuses i came in
there uh
my best self and he still beat me with a
close decision so he's uh he's an
absolute freak you know there's there's
some fights maybe i fought her or didn't
have a good training camp but that one i
trained perfect for went in there and
still came up short
something really interesting that i saw
um in the news i think it just came out
actually and the ufc news the other day
um
was that you they're banning the flags
so you know when you come out and you
have like whatever country you're from
yeah um and i believe that's something
to do with russia
do you know more about this do you have
a take on it i don't but i know one of
my uh i think it sucks i think she'll
come with your flags but one of my
fighters i trained an english kid um
javid basharat who's actually he's uh he
was born in afghanistan so he wanted to
come out with the afghanistan flag for
his last fight you know i put we got the
flag on our shoulder to walk out like oh
you can't walk out with that flag
because taliban's now in charge of the
government and that's not their official
flag but like i know a lot of afghan
people and that's the flag they all
they all post that flag no one's posting
the taliban flag so they wouldn't let
him walk out with his flag and i know he
was i mean he took it well but it was it
was kind of lame so maybe it's stuff
like that like they don't want uh
you know the people might look at one
flag the government has a different one
so it gets a little complicated
personally i think they should allow it
but i think it's something to do with
that
yeah i mean like the ufc is supposed to
just be about like
getting down to business doing the
fights not caring about political
correctness you know if that's the flag
you want to have that's your flag
yeah i agree and uh i don't think dana
white's a good person but he's been
great with dealing political correctness
you know
that's one thing
even though i don't really like him that
much i think he's i'll give him credit
where it's due like he uh he tried not
to stop at all during the lockdowns
which i had mad respect for he was
actually he was going to do a show on um
a native american indian land in
california because they don't uh they
don't follow california laws but our
dumb ass governor went uh when called
the head of disney to get it canceled
it's like what a like california doesn't
own that land but somehow in his mind he
tried saying like they owned his land
because in california like talk about
not respecting the native american
culture oh wow i didn't know that that's
insane
yeah because he has no jurisdiction over
the native american indian land but in
his mind he said he did because it was
you know within california limits but
it's not considered california when he
went overstepped in my opinion
overstepped his uh his boundaries by by
getting that show cancelled
gavin knew some stuff
yeah he said you probably know much
about him he's a terrible governor
yes i've heard he likes to um enforce
rules and then not keep them um just
like most politicians um so let let's go
let's go into america um and i guess
also just your fighting background so
how important would you say physical
challenges in helping you take on
reality um and the natural
struggles that life will inevitably
bring you
first off i think physical activity is
absolutely crucial for every human but
men in particular i think really need to
do something physical and rough i think
maybe that's uh maybe that's part of the
decline in america culture you get these
weak men with low testosterone and like
um and weak they have no confidence and
they're weird and they start attacking
and trying to tear everything apart
instead of build it up and that's why
fighting and even jujitsu which is way
less intense than fighting the whole jiu
jitsu industry that thinks the same too
it's it's it's not the same you're not
getting punched but you're still getting
choked you're getting your shoulders
cranked it's uh
that's what i've been trying to tell
people if you have kids especially boys
but but girls too put them in jiu jitsu
it's gonna it's gonna build them
character gonna make them tougher also
if they ever need to if they get a fight
you're gonna be able to win but it just
makes you a a better person i think it's
humbling because all of us have had bad
days where there's some dude on your
back or laying on crushing you or
choking you and it's uh it's a very
humbling experience to get choked out
and punched in the face
and do you feel like getting choked out
and punched in the face helps you take
on
other things in life like if someone's
saying being rude or if someone's you
know i don't know whatever people cry
about these days i think it does and the
weird part is for me i was you know
getting a lot of trouble as a kid
getting in fights getting arrested as
soon as i started fighting
professionally i didn't do anything
anymore i had no desire to fight someone
talked about me i could just be like i
don't care i could beat this guy up i
don't need to prove anything i think the
only times i've gotten a couple couple
fights you got it after i came with pro
fighters when someone insult my friends
for some reason that uh that still
really bothers me but it got to the
point where they talked about me i'm
like i know you beat this guy i don't
need to prove anything
that makes sense
so for you you know you mentioned blm
you mentioned the lockdowns but what
would you say is
sort of the biggest problem for you
right now
it's all like complicated everything's
kind of tied together with the you know
they have the
it's almost like a bunch you point out
it's almost like a marxism coming in
we're trying to like
trying to change what's true and what's
not the weird it's it's all tied in like
you know the whole the whole trans
things which i have no no problem with
trans people i actually just did an
interview with um with blair white he
hung out with her she was extremely nice
woman i have no problem calling her a
woman but she now if she went trying to
play a woman's sport then i would call
her out and have a problem with it but
she gets it that's wrong she just she
prefers you know being that way so i
have no problem someone wants to do that
but to try to tell the reality of us to
tell us that that isn't a man that
that's where it gets weird and and then
the worst part is the shift to doing
other kids now which i have a daughter
who went through these schools you know
we're in one of the most liberal places
in uh in america so it's probably her
school before most other places but that
you know because she's a little older
now but i remember pushing us
through her school there's pushing this
weird you know you can pick your gender
there's all these like trans kids at
schools it's like they're encouraging it
the kids that would go along with it
would get treated better so i think if
you have kids it's very important that
you have like honest critical
conversations with them don't try to
pressure that your views are right but
ask them questions make them uh make
them learn to think for themselves
otherwise you know because they're
getting bombarded a good chance they're
getting bombarded by their teachers kids
getting told weird stuff like they can
pick their genders and who knows what
else
it's so bizarre because like i'm only my
i'm only in my 20s but like
so it's not like that long ago but it's
you know still long ago since i was a
child but we never had those
conversations um yeah
it's just weird i i don't know when this
sudden shift happened well here's
another weird one there's a fighter i
know if i can say any names but uh yes
he has a daughter in school you know and
uh
the teacher was telling her people
aren't gonna like you because you're
mexican
he was furious he's like why would you
tell my daughter that like i get i get
treated completely normal and you're
putting my daughter head the white
people aren't gonna like her and she's
like half white and they're not gonna
like her because of her latinx or
whatever the teeth are trying to say but
at least he uh
when you know i think he went chew the
teacher out and like you know don't
don't don't fill my kid's head full of
this bs
that just perpetuates every like the
whole cycle of problems and poverty by
you know teaching someone victim
mentality from such a young age
it 100 does and you know like that's
what i know is my daughter's school and
luckily my uh
you know my my friend he uh he saw this
right away and went in confronted the
teachers once he started talking to his
daughter seeing what they were teaching
unfortunately you know i never went in
front of the teachers i think that was
the peak of my fight career my mind was
too lazy to focus on that but i did talk
to my daughter and ask her questions and
see what they're being taught and you
know
i would i would have honest
conversations and taught her to
critically think and then she'd go in
and challenge the teachers and they
would get mad at her and yell at her and
call her stupid but at least it got her
to you know at least she was confident
enough to go and challenge him and
realize there's other ways of thinking
that's wild the closest i came to um
that kind of political indoctrination
was um when i was 17 they would i was in
an american politics class and it was so
liberal so left-wing and i wasn't really
like smart enough at the time but there
was a guy in the in class he was like
super conservative very capitalist
um and
yeah he got kicked out of class because
he kept interrupting he kept saying
you're teaching with a you're teaching
with the narrative
yeah a lot of these teachers they don't
want to be challenged at all it's weird
because when i was in school they they
didn't i didn't know paul i had no idea
what any of my teachers were i didn't
know what the politics were i didn't
know if they were gay or straight i
didn't know there's no reason i should
know this correct but it's changed so
much in such a fast period of time i
think um
people are finally starting to see it
now but i don't think stealing the level
it's at
and it's weird you know my daughter went
to marin so it probably creeped in that
school a little earlier but it seems
like it's creeping all over the country
yeah i think in the uk as well actually
because i was at a dinner a few weeks
ago um and a woman was telling me her
daughter is having these kind of
conversations um
but you you mentioned you mentioned um
blair white she's super cool and i i
there's two things you mentioned i want
to ask you so number one the first
question is how come you have no problem
calling her a woman because most people
don't
yeah i just think because it's
respectful to do because she treated me
nice i liked her and um
if you go if you ask me hey is that
really a woman i'm gonna tell you no you
know it's not but i think you'll be
disrespectful if if she's treating me
with respect why wouldn't i shoot her
with respect and i would think uh i
think she's great for the community
because all the trans i'd seen on uh
online all the trans activists they made
me start to like question and be like
man these trans people are psychopaths
they're like they're defending a guy
who's like jerking off in a girl's
bathroom and like playing women's sports
all i was seeing was negative with trans
and that's like the first uh trans
person i hung out with out in austin i'm
like oh she's actually really nice she's
smart i can talk to her to get along so
maybe obviously it's still weird for
condition but at least she can see that
she's not trying to say it's like normal
and she gets it and she's a nice nice
intelligent person so
okay all trans people aren't bad and
they need they need to put places like
her up to get except to get accepted not
the ones they're putting up they're
putting these weird creepy sociopaths
the trans activists instead of someone
who's smart and intelligent like blair
yeah i think that's the point because
everybody because you sort of like
aren't allowed to have a conversation
about this because they saw or sort of
automatically think that you know you're
inciting violence and all this stuff
which is obviously not true
um
and
yeah you're right blair is like super
smart intelligent respectful so why
would you want to offend her if she if
she says i'd like you to call me she
yeah like
sure
i don't know
i'm not yeah i'm not going to pretend
like it's she was really a woman but i'm
willing to call her a girl it's like
disrespectful not to if she's
respectable to me like it would be it'd
be rude not to so yeah i've no problem
calling her girl as long as she doesn't
try
the part is they're trying to make you
believe it really is a girl there's no
difference by a biology biology and
clearly you know if she was to fight
another woman now she would have huge
advantages
well let's get into that because that
was my second point how do you feel um
about
yeah trans um
[Music]
trans women in women's sports so
biological men in women's sports
um i mean it's absolutely ridiculous
you're not gonna give someone estrogen
for a year they're gonna be weaker they
might get a little weaker but it's not
gonna be massive i mean
it's it's
as you've noticed there's never been a
trans uh what was it a trans man they
compete in women's sports still they
don't compete women in men's sports even
though their testosterone because it
doesn't make you know they're too weak
so it just doesn't make sense and i
think um we are seeing some improvement
in that because i remember like a year
or so ago when i post stuff about it i
would just get all hate i know a lot of
people believe with me but believe what
i said but no people be afraid to
especially girls they'd be afraid to
comment on my post like my post like on
instagram you could just tell they were
scared you know they probably believed
they probably see it and agree with what
i said but they wouldn't say anything
but after this swimming incident i would
post stuff and i just saw the tide shift
i saw tons of girls commented on it and
uh i think it's extremely generally you
know i'm not a feminist and i think it's
a man's job to fight for a woman but i
think in this particular instance women
are gonna have to stand up for
themselves because what happens when
women aren't saying anything everyone's
like well the women don't care why do
you care that's what everyone kept
telling me so it was great to see women
finally start to speak up over this last
uh i think the swimming incident was so
absurd they realized wow we really are
going to get all of our sports taken
away men are able to come into our
bathrooms and and you know you know the
bathroom one gets it uh gets tricky
because someone like blair probably
could use the woman's bathroom without
being a problem but the problem is you
can get a creepy guy that can just be
identified as a woman and come in there
and they will do it there are creepy
guys out there for sure you know
there's creepy guys out there that'll do
creepy [ __ ] they get away with
yeah you make so many good points i mean
do you ever
because swimming
it's infiltrated swimming right so and
and weightlifting as well
as a professional fighter do you think
this will start to infiltrate um
the ufc
uh it's already been in pro fighting
there's been two of them that have
fought obviously you know beat girls up
but uh the ufc is gonna be hard because
i know dana's not gonna want it
but the ufc is owned by disney disney's
huge on this trans stuff so it gets a
little complicated there might be a
power struggle at some point rather does
dana white make the decisions or do the
execs of disney make the decisions
yeah and i think
the point you made as well about women
um i'm also not a feminist um i think
it's annoying and it gives me a headache
and i think it's counterproductive
um
that's for another for another show um
but but i but i do think you know it is
it is a it is i think a man's job in
this world is to protect women like i
think that's what he's on this planet
for um
she has other roles he has roles um but
you're right if women
don't start speaking up then we're going
to be in a lot of trouble yeah and i and
i think you i don't i think you'd be
great if we didn't have speak up i think
it should be our job to protect them
they shouldn't have to speak up but
unfortunately it seems like they have to
in this situation because they were it's
just this is too weird if it's only the
men speaking up it gives the other side
to be like well only men care and
clearly
most women agree like almost
most people agree with what we say but
they make you think it's the opposite
like remember one time i was talking uh
crap about a fighter uh you know man
that beat up a woman and it's by by far
the hardest i've ever been spammed on
twitter you know i had hundreds of uh
of um inboxes telling me to hate me and
thousands of messages telling me how
stupid i was it's a i'm a smart person
because i can see this not the real real
world this is just like hate mobs online
or maybe even bots but you can see if
you've never had hate in your life how
they could freak someone out like i've
i've been hating fighting before i've
had people throw [ __ ] at me been booed
by thousands of people it's
i can handle a hate mob but if you've
never had a hate mob and you have 10 000
people telling you kill yourself you're
a piece of [ __ ] you're you're a bigot
you can see how people would get scared
and back down and be like okay maybe i
was wrong and not want to fight it
yeah it gets brutal out there um it gets
really really aggressive um
but no i i i think that it's definitely
a strange situation to be in um
and
do you do you think there's any point
whereby like hormones could really
equalize the playing field
um not that they have now maybe they
could have been something but i don't
think there's no way to do it and it's
um yeah it's unfortunate you know if
trans can't compete in sports but it
just might be the reality of it you
can't take for a small tiny bit of
population and kill women's sports or
they can go you know if you're trans
women you compete in men's sports or you
can get a trans league and yeah it sucks
for them but they're just not a large
enough percentage of population to
completely screw over women you know
it's uh you know it's just not fair to
completely destroy their sports and it's
a it's an athlete i think that one you
know
i take it seriously because i know how
much work we put into sports and i do
think less women put the kind of work in
sports men's do but but the ones at the
top they do they do sacrifice their
whole life trying to make it to the top
and if you have these girls they're just
grinding grind trying to win a national
champ and someone comes in there
switches over you know from a man to a
woman and goes and takes their title
away that they've spent you know in some
cases 15 years struggling to win it's
just uh that one really gets me because
i can relate being an athlete
i guess it's funny because it's not the
other way around right but you sort of
mentioned this earlier so is it doesn't
that just sort of like prove the point
it completely does but there's quiet on
it and the trans men they actually
compete against women because they know
they can't stand a chance against men
and they allow them to take steroids so
they get to go in there on steroids
because they're trans so they can they
can break the rules it's completely
unfair and stupid
has there been a trans man by so a
biological woman that has beaten a man a
biological man
in any sport or fighting definitely uh
i don't think it's too likely i mean
they'll be one-offs i'm sure there's
some girls that you know could be some
guys in some sports but a girl's never
gonna uh a girl is never gonna be the
top guy
that's the whole debate you know i
remember like rhonda rousey's amazing
but there was one point where joe
rogan's like oh i think she'd take some
of the men in the ufc it's like come on
joe i love you but
if you really think a woman's gonna be
the top fighter yeah she's gonna beat up
an average dude for sure on the streets
but not a professional fighter
yeah no that makes sense i think it's
funny because um i don't really believe
in the patriarchy as such
but like if there was a patriarchy like
this is the patriarchy it's like men
taking over women's swords
no it is and that's that part of me
wants to just laugh it's not being a
feminist it's like oh men win again
we're taking your sports we're taking
your locker rooms part of it's like
funny and i want to just laugh but then
you look at it it's like you know it's
disgusting i have a daughter it's like
uh
it's you know it's just not fair there's
well you know men and women are
different there's no reason why we
shouldn't have separate spaces you know
i like it when i go to the gym and it's
all men and we can you know have
camaraderie and get along and maybe
that's part of the reason why fighters
uh
think one way because we go and big
groups of men and we hang out we talk
crap to each other we beat each other up
and we have like uh a group people you
can relate to i think women need that
too
yeah well women women we can't do that
we're not built that way
basically unfortunately that's the
reality of it i much prefer the way the
men do it it's better um but yeah okay
speaking of that locker room
style
and talk and things like that um freedom
of speech is massively um under attack
and um elon musk sort of seems like he's
here to save the day so i'd like to get
your thoughts on elon musk um acquiring
twitter do you think this is actually
going to improve the whole sphere
i think it will you know it's you never
know what his real motives are but he
seems he seems pretty genuine i think he
really cares about free speech i mean
he's a guy who too i think a year or two
ago started kind of putting his real
thoughts out there he was the guy i
never knew anything about and i think
the i think the lockdown sort of got to
him he started slowly putting little
things out like this sucks and now he's
like he's one of the best people on
twitter he fully puts on i'm sure he has
a whole self out there but he puts on
all kinds of interesting intriguing
tweets that uh none other billionaires
are doing he puts a little personality
out there and shows he cares about free
speech and he was anti-lockdown which is
uh
which is huge you know
and stuff stuff like that and i'm sure i
don't agree with everything but he seems
like uh he's one of the more interesting
men
of our entire generation i mean he gets
hate a lot but the guy you know
revolutionized you know banking with
paypal
uh electric cars with tesla which you
know i'm not even from environment but i
have a tesla because they're amazing
cars like you know people hate on it but
you drive those things like you don't
even really want to drive the cars after
that it's like they're so quick i can
put self-driving on let my car drive
itself it's like he makes he makes a
good [ __ ] car people can hate on it
because it's electric but you think the
left's like i'm unsure if electric cars
are better for the environment but
that's what the left's saying and then
they hate the guy who does that you know
and he's revolutionized rocket ships and
now hopefully he's uh
he's defending free speech i'm pretty
sure he's sincere i know a lot of people
say he's not but i think he's sincere
with wanting to protect free speech
yeah i do agree i think he's also
sincere um but speaking of that that
hypocrisy um did you see
um the tweet that he did where um bill
gates asked if he would
invest in his philanthropy or whatever
and he was like but you still have a
really big short position on tesla
anyway i didn't see that tweet but
that's it
but i heard him mention something about
how he heard that uh he had a huge short
against them it's uh yeah yeah they're
really trying to short the company that
would save the environment they're
saying they're environmentalists it's uh
i think i mean i actually had a lot of
friends that shorts against tesla
because they didn't they thought he was
over hyping it and it was going to
collapse and to be fair it was you know
there was one point where the company
could have collapsed but i just uh you
know i didn't have one at that point but
i drove the cars and i'm like man this
company's gonna come through this guy
makes too good of cars but it is
possible to make a great product and uh
and still fell
but like luckily elon musk managed to
push through and they're i think the
most uh things are the biggest car
company in the world now
yeah i mean i'm also not that like
big and crazy on fixing the environment
or whatever i don't know but the cars
are amazing the the screen and the way
you can see the people walking
wow you know he just makes a good a good
car you can't deny that you know if i
had other expensive cars but the tesla
drives it dries up with it it can
compete with cars that are way more
expensive that's my opinion yeah there
may be like you know some some elite
elite cars might not drive them but
they're gonna be way more expensive way
more expensive to maintain
saying too once you get a tesla there's
zero money to maintain it zero gas it
just drives
so are there just back to elon musk and
free speech and stuff like that are
there um
any accounts that you think are gonna
come back like do you think donald trump
will be reinstated
i think he will if he comes back because
he has his own um true social which is
stupid because these niche ones just
don't work no one wants to or some
people want to i don't want to go in a
circle jerk where everyone thinks
exactly the same that's why i went on
gab or one of those for a second i'm
like it's all it is is everyone thinks
exactly the same i like following
liberal accounts and seeing how i like
seeing other people think i don't i'm
not trying to put myself in a
in a little like easy box where everyone
says the exact same thing and that's
what truth social is going to be it's
funny we're probably not some little
liberal ones start up that are huge for
uh huge censorship this is going to be
you know they won't get big though
that's why they'll ban themselves into
like non-existence
and that's what elon everyone kept
telling elon to start a new show a new
one but he realized it was too late
twitter has become the place and you
can't you can't change that now so even
though even when i hated twitter i never
threatened to leave because i knew that
was where the dialogue happens and it is
people aren't on twitter they don't
realize how um impactful it is they're
like oh most people aren't on there but
it's where all the news is shaped all
the information is put out there first
is where people are fact checked when
they try lying people on twitter will go
out there and see you know you get the
only place you can see the truth
and that's why they're so scared of the
elon buying it because they want to be
able to control what we see and what we
don't
so on that point because you did tweet
about that actually you tweeted saying
that the elites are freaking out over
elon buying twitter um i agree and i
think many work celebrities um are
threatened that their accounts are get
an er um go or they're threatening to
lose their own delete their own accounts
i think actually some british ones have
actually left to it already um but
say that again sorry but they'll be back
they'll be back yeah yeah yeah exactly
um but what okay so why do you think
then
it was celebrated when jeff bezos bought
the washington post it was like
celebrated as this huge cultural
innovation this huge cultural shift and
then elon musk wants to buy twitter and
everyone's crying
well because jeff bezos is going to play
along with the narrative and they know
that and elon musk might not and it's
like uh
they they could always censor through
the mainstream media what we saw before
and it's like you know everyone talks
about oh how about how fake the media
has became maybe they've always been
that fake and we just couldn't tell if
you didn't have twitter to fact check
them i mean there's there's so much
stuff throughout history that who knows
they've been lying to us all along you
know you see things like you know they
convinced us that iraq had weapons of
mass destruction and pushed us into that
war with twitter people probably fact
checked it and seeing that that was you
know fake statistics and uh you know
doc fauci has a lot of time any doctors
that disagree with his age theory he was
pushed off he gets him pulled off tv
there was nowadays they could go on
twitter and say their theory because a
lot of people don't think fauci's aid
theory is correct which it is a little
weird you know straight people aren't
out catching aids
yeah you tweeted about that um
can you go into that in a bit more
detail because i think i'm like i'm a
bit too young to know what happened
i don't know the exact all the details
but i just know it doesn't smash past
the smell test because when i was a kid
they pushed non-stop fear for out having
sex with condoms we're all going to
catch aids and um
you know the way colleges are nightlife
scene people have a lot of unprotected
sex aids would be everywhere but for
whatever reason aids only passed between
gay people and
uh intravenous needle users if you ask
someone to name a straight person with
aids the only person they'll say is
magic johnson but then he never got sick
he never crossed over and got sick from
aids he never he's still healthy so if
you can name one straight person in the
entire world that's uh that's a little
bit strange to me when they're telling
us you catch it this way now they do
have aids in africa but it has different
characteristics and it but africa is
extremely dirty place dirty sewage
there's a lot going on so it's hard to
say uh
what it is but you don't realize aids is
simply it's when your immune system
attacks itself and you start having a
lower immune system it's not necessarily
one disorder there could be different
ways people are getting it and you know
i i don't know the exact answer what it
is but clearly we should put some
research on it and there is some major
you know doctors that disagree with
voucher but they just get pushed out and
they're scared to question them i know
there are theories out there i just
personally don't know what they are
you tweeted something about um your
cousin if you don't mind me bringing
that up you said that he had aids he was
doing fine and then he took a drug that
felt she was pushing
yeah man that was terrible because when
i was a little kid and that was the time
too fauci was saying like you know maybe
you can get aids being close contacts i
was close to my cousin but then i would
get scared being around them and he was
doing okay with aids and they put him on
the stuff azt
and as soon as he went on it he just you
know got sick it's like he's a chemo
drug he started getting sick and then
died within a couple months it seemed to
just uh
put him out i was recently doing some
reading on azd and a lot of people think
that's actually what the biggest cause
the deaths were in aids because there
was hardly any aids deaths dr fauci
pushed
azt started pushing out in the public
aids deaths spiked ass actu spiked then
all of a sudden they realized they were
giving people weight way too much azt
they cut it way way down and then the
deaths of hiv dropped down to almost
nothing now you're hardly sure about
people dying of aids
wow so a lot of people think that
actually the biggest part of the aids
epidemic was fauci killing people with
azt
that's insane like i don't know about
this
i didn't either what was this
like it was like the late 80s and 90s
and i didn't either but i remember like
when fauci first took over the thing
like oh seems like a nice guy my friend
john joseph of crowmax was ranting about
what a sociopath evil guy this is and
i'm like huh it's interesting john
thinks this album but after recently
going back and
going back and looking and seeing all
the stuff you do you're like wow this
guy really is uh really is a bad guy and
uh you know all the ties to the drug
companies he has and all that he
controls i believe 100 of the funding
for infectious disease so he can control
what gets uh studied and what doesn't so
you can't like study any any other
theories than what he tells you to
so the question then is
is this is is this driven by money
is this driven by some people talk about
depopulation
what do you think
yeah i see i i don't really know my
guess would be money in power but
sometimes it's hard to so many people
just seem so evil you try being like why
do you need more money like why are you
doing this stuff like you know why are
you why are you torturing puppies but
getting them eaten up by flies like
can you explain that well that to me as
well because you tweeted that before you
went live and i didn't have time to like
be like what is this talking about they
did this weird experiment on these flies
that they might have some kind of flesh
eating thing and they put them on these
puppies and let them like slowly eat
them alive why they and some of them
lasted up to like 100 like 90 something
days that they tortured them until they
totally died of just like eating beef
little cute beagle puppies too it's like
why'd they do that
they were trying to see what what kind
of effect the flies would have on the
skin or something
i don't know i'd have to do with exact
study but it was they have they have a
reason they're going to argue they're
testing something but that's we don't
wait
yeah you shouldn't test something by
torturing puppies
yeah it's just it's just so crazy um
it's very strange um but you you were
recently on joe rogan um it's not gone
live yet am i right it's not it went out
it went out a couple weeks ago
he was on the mma show because he has
the mma show and the um
and the regular podcast because i was
looking for it
yeah so i think they kind of separate
the mma and the um
and uh we talked like half politics half
of may but you know when most the
fighters obviously go on mma show
okay well i'll i'll i'll check it out so
tell me how was that
it's pretty cool it's kind of weird
because it's like three hours that's a
long time to talk and you're kind of
sitting there and you're like um
after three hours you kind of you know i
i didn't have a watch never clocks
completely lost track of time so you
weren't really sure and then he kind of
stops the show and you're like you walk
out and you're like damn what do we just
talk about knowing there's probably
millions of people listening you're like
well i hope it wasn't too stupid but uh
luckily i've only gotten good feedback
i'm sure there's a few haters are like
you suck but overall i was like oh you
did really good so it's uh you know it's
definitely not like nerve-wracking but
it's a little weird you're saying
they're just chatting back and forth but
joe makes you comfortable he's a guy
i've known for years so it wasn't uh it
wasn't too weird getting on him
and like i said we're fighting you do
you don't think about like oh building
people to watch me fight don't think
about like oh like 10 million people
might watch this interview you just kind
of yeah want to relax and [ __ ]
and joe you know he's a funny guy so we
were kind of our conversation uh
flowed the whole time you know he's a
great conversationalist because three
hours the conversation never stopped
that's uh that's pretty impressive to be
able to do that
let me think it's just impressive to be
able to go on anyway and be able to talk
for three hours um you said you spoke
about politics and fighting what did you
talk about when it came to politics
ah man we were kind of all over the
place we didn't get into any like really
big details any little elon musk and to
be honest i haven't rewatched it and i
can like
i can hardly even i remember it people
were telling me like oh you talked about
this and i'll be like oh yeah kinda
but it gets weird uh
watch myself give interviews i'll
probably overthink things so i'm like
i'm just not gonna watch it i'm too too
critical of myself
yeah i could i can imagine um but no i i
definitely need to need to check that
out so in terms of just like fighting
aside but just you know talking about
everything that's going on in the world
um how driven are you like how
um like how far do you want to go are
you just gonna like tweet about it talk
about it like
what are your what are your plans i mean
i have no set question set plans right
now you know ultimately i try to you
know look i think the best thing you can
do is look out for yourself make sure
you're just saying yourself make sure
you're making money for yourself your
family around you and uh take care of
yourself first but it is nice to try to
help people you know the first things uh
twitter i mean i have thought about
politics but then you start looking into
it you're like man this is a mess do i
really want to get involved in this
yeah
yeah it's it's a hard one um i think it
was i think jordan peterson was sort of
talking about the shift in his life um
you know he was just a normal man and
then suddenly he's sort of like the most
loved and hated person simultaneously
um
but humanity needs him
yeah i know it's weird i think it's it's
uh
a lot of times i pick your mind people
like you more and people will hate you
more so you if you can deal with that go
ahead to me it doesn't bother me being
hated so i don't really care i mean i
have all my friends and and whatnot
something that cracks me up is all the
time people will like dm me or ask on a
post like what does uh what is the one
of you i guess pretty famous friends
like what is nate or what does chuck
think of your opinions and it's like
dude they're my friends do you really
think they're going on my twitter i mean
they might read my twitter but you
really think they're look at this and
get mad at me we like we're like
brothers we've been friends forever
we we obviously agree on a lot of stuff
but if we happen to post something they
don't agree with sounds like we're not
going to be friends and some of these
people i feel bad for them if you have a
friend that want to be your friend
because something you post on twitter
unfortunately it's like it's like that
some places these these liberal places
you post the wrong stuff i mean
conservatives do it a little bit but at
the moment it's definitely uh
liberals that are pushing for the
craziness you know i never consider
myself a conservative but i get lumped
in
you know by being pro free speech you
know anti-lock downs i mean i do like
lower taxes that type of stuff you get
considered like far right
yeah i mean i'm i'm actually um one of
those people unfortunately that just
like lost a ton of friends um because of
all of this like um
like i just don't
i just don't align with the whole
feminist narrative um i just think it's
like self-hating um to be honest um
and really counterproductive um and all
my friends were like crazy about the
lockdown like i had a friend who i went
for a walk with her in 2020 the
beginning of the pandemic in the park
and she like was like
miles away from me jesus and i was and i
was just like whatever you know like i
went home and i was sort of like telling
my family about it and i was just like
whatever you know it's good to have
friends and people around you
um so i never cut them off but they cut
me off in the end because
they couldn't take my views
yeah i mean just sometimes it's just
people grow apart and that's reality
they can't take who you are but this is
who you are i think you're gonna be a
lot happier speaking your mind and uh
and making real friends and trying to be
fake and you know i just noticed
i had friends that were like that who
you know their friends were all the way
but they didn't believe that way and
they're trying to trying to fake it and
get along and fit in with them and it's
it's tough it's like do you really want
to pretend like you agree with these
people but that's how hateful they are
if you don't they're going to try to cut
you out and that's that's to me like i
do have friends that are liberal i have
no problem with it people that you know
i like having debates hearing my friends
opinions and why
that's when you have real friends but
people that get get weird and they can't
have friends other opinions it's uh it's
on them
it's on them um okay so just last topic
um you dm me about crypto have you
bought any crypto yet
a tiny bit of like bitcoin ethereum but
but not much i need it's down now so now
it's probably a good time to start
buying it so yeah it's tragic we're at
we're at 30.8 right now i'm like oh i'm
watching while i when i'm oh wow maybe
i'll go buy some right after we get off
this that's that's
you never know what it's going to do but
it seems like the stock market's down
too it's uh inflation's high it's
definitely not a good time for uh for
anything real estate the interest rates
are going up so houston's probably gonna
come down so it's like uh where do you
put your money if you hold it in cash
it's losing value
and the stock market bitcoin is not
doing great so it's a it's a tough time
but i think uh like i said most more
money is like in stocks now i think it
would make sense to put some of it in
crypto in your opinion do you just do
bitcoin or you do anything else
um okay so i get called like a bitcoin
maximalist which basically means i think
bitcoin is the best but i'm not a
bitcoin maximalist by some definition so
i think that bitcoin is the ultimate
store of value despite the fact that
it's down i think long term it is the
ultimate store of value i think it's the
best form of money that there is um i
think everything else is quite
interesting and so i do invest in other
things um but i'm also very very aware
of the fact that they are projects they
are centralized and they are startups
and so that's why i don't really promote
very much about the other coins that i
buy as an example i hold solana right
like i don't really talk about this too
much um i hold solana um
and um but solana is very centralized
it's very vc funded um and the network
gets turned on and off again so like i
wouldn't actively like tell people to
buy solana because
it's just a gamble and it's not good
money you know
yeah yeah i bought a little dogecoin
real quick and made some money real
quick but but i bought it knowing it was
stupid i just saw elon musk tweeted
about it real quick like oh i'm gonna go
buy some of that real quick and then it
shot up shot of almost 100 times
unfortunately i didn't sell it at the
top but still you know it went up so
much that obviously i was gonna make
some money
yeah that's amazing that's good um you
need to you need to get in um you need
to know where you can be getting your
good interest rates you need to know how
to take self-custody do you know about
that yet self-custody no what's that so
it's essentially keeping your money um
so when you leave your money in the bank
you don't actually own it like they can
freeze your funds right like we saw in
canada actually it's like they did in
canada yeah that was kind of a wake-up
call like man i need to i need to
actually buy bitcoin not buy bitcoin
through like these apps
well that's the point so like the ceo of
um i think it was kraken which is
another exchange he told his he told his
um customers who were based in canada he
said if if it comes down to it we will
legally have to freeze your funds so
withdraw your money so where do you
withdraw it you take it
um and you take self-custody and you
move it off the exchange and you hold it
directly just you and the blockchain
that's it no intermediary just you and
the blockchain so nobody can freeze your
funds yes so that's the really exciting
part
yeah i think that to me is the most
intriguing thing about bitcoin
especially because what happened in
canada we've never seen that you know in
modern times and the western government
sees money but the fact of canada would
do it we're not much different i mean
biden would happily do anything that
should always do might be a little
harder in the us but they can do it
there it's reality they could do it here
yeah exactly and um
yeah basically but the thing with
bitcoin is if it's sitting on an
exchange it can be taken yeah they can't
freeze it yeah
so at least you have like so if they
freeze your freezer bank account you
still have money in the bitcoin so you
still have no i'm saying you they can no
i'm saying they can they can't use your
bitcoin if it's on an exchange if it's
on exchange exactly but if you have the
what your own keys which which is what i
need to do because i don't have that yet
so right now i don't really have bitcoin
okay well we'll teach you how to do that
another time but yeah it's just so
amazing and i think what's so
interesting is would you say canada was
like a real wake-up moment for you then
when it came to bitcoin
with the bitcoin yeah you know i already
thought it was interesting and you know
i wanted to get some but seeing that
it's like oh shoot i i really better buy
some you know my accounts i have the
wrong opinions my accounts could get
shut down and all of a sudden you have
no freedom you shut your bank account
you can't you know
you can't drive you can't eat you can't
you can't do anything
do you know about central bank digital
currencies
is that the one the governments are
trying to make or uh yeah i've heard a
little bit about it but don't know a lot
yeah i think i feel like they want to go
to track every dollar they want to know
uh what you spend you can't cheat taxes
that way they want to see where your
money's going they can shut your money
off if they want i think that's the
future they want but hopefully the
people push back and resist it
yeah there you go you're super clued up
when it comes to crypto you know what
you're talking about you got it
i know a little bit a lot of friends are
in it luckily uh i had friends that were
in it early they were getting it for
like a couple hundred dollars
yeah wow
obviously didn't sell at the top but
that's the friends made pretty good
money on bitcoin it's like man i wish i
would have been buying it then
yeah well despite the fact that it's
down like i always say this i i think
bitcoin's going to a million i don't
know when maybe 10 years 15 years um i'd
say 500 000 in the next five years don't
quote me but i'm comfortable to say that
because i think i think it's happening
um and yeah central bank digital
currencies are insane they're just
programmable money so like if you don't
have your vaccine or whatever it is then
you know you may not be able to go spend
you may not be able to buy certain
things like i think it was in canada you
weren't allowed into um certain um
supermarkets unchaperoned um to make
sure that you were only buying essential
items so you were buying let's just say
like food as opposed to i don't know
toys or whatever
yeah i think australia too
right so with a central bank digital
currency you don't need the chaperone it
just becomes a far more uh efficient way
to discriminate basically yeah and i
definitely see him doing this you know i
i spent i i was 20 years in san
francisco and they made it so i couldn't
go in a restaurant couldn't i mean like
i moved out of there but when i visited
i couldn't even go to restaurant
couldn't go into bar i mean people left
me in bars because people know me and
didn't ask me for a thing and i could go
restaurants people went to ask but
technically they weren't supposed to let
me in anywhere luckily there was a few
good people that you know weren't
forcing the rules but it's just that's
absurd the city passed the past and you
know majority people were happy to go
along with like let's cut the
unvaccinated people out of society it's
like they tried to come back outside a
year ago and i think we're just gonna
forget
yeah i'm not forgetting i'm like i'm not
forgetting at all um so you so you spent
a lot of time in san francisco so many
years have you officially left
yeah i'm in las vegas now i had uh
during the lockdowns they were just so
extreme i'm like i gotta get out of here
city was getting you see everything a
liberal city doesn't want to do they did
wrong just the homelessness the
dirtiness the drug addicts over the
streets the crime rate spiking lockdowns
for a year the gym i was running you
know we got close close down for a year
people could go to the gym you know we
were there working out illegally but how
are you gonna stay in business when you
still have rent to pay and you don't
have money coming in and you know we're
not gonna charge people when they're not
working out so it's uh i was thankful
that you know i knew all the gym owners
i don't know what i've done if i
couldn't work out i had like uh
at that point all my work i was doing
was shut down i had nothing to do to sit
around the house and i'm not uh to me
that's not mentally healthy to sit
around do nothing i had to go and work
out and go and do stuff and uh but
luckily i was able to find people pretty
quick that were willing to go to jitsu
with me jiu jitsu is probably the worst
thing you could do according to the
kogan rules but hey i never got sick the
last couple years
that is i keep knocking this mic um that
is that is wild um i was at a party
actually the other day and i met a girl
from san francisco and just given i'm
like heavily living on twitter in the
metaphors
um you know i hear people complaining
all the time about san francisco so i
said to her i was like oh i hear san
francisco so bad and she's like no it's
not
and i was like oh i heard there's
homeless everywhere and she's like no
it's not that's just what the
conservatives are saying to make you
think that it's and i was like well i've
never been so i don't really know
i mean things have to go there are some
areas that are like not as bad but the
homelessness drug ass usually push into
a small area and that area keeps
expanding and expanding so pretty much
taking over the whole the whole downtown
area now there are areas in san
francisco you can go where they're not
there and the same thing with the crime
too though used to be you know they'd
get you certain spots but now they're
going through residential neighborhoods
stealing your cars home invasions
robberies it's just getting uh more and
more lava lawless the d.a there won't
really prosecute crime i mean he's so
extreme though even san francisco is
recalling him because his parents are
actually were in prison for killing
three cops so this guy hated police and
then somehow he's the one in charge of
putting people in jail
wow yeah i heard this someone was
telling me that
you're not that you that you could steal
up to like a certain amount of money and
then they're not going to come after you
that's i think it's all california
that's 9.50 so they can't arrest you if
you steal less than 950 so the cops
won't come so they break in their car
that's how point you come if you call
them
so they don't think it doesn't matter
yeah they can come up to you and you can
just tell the cop to [ __ ] off and keep
walking away
makes no sense these laws
wow okay
all right so i won't be won't be moving
to california i'll be staying
comfortable here in florida
yeah florida seems like one of the ones
florida texas a few free states a lot of
the states they talk about too you know
like arizona montana these places are
extremely free they just kind of fly
under the radar
yeah probably for the best um so nobody
comes knocking they'll change anything
exactly montana don't want people coming
oh really that's funny i'll have to i
have to look into that um okay so do you
have any um anything that like you're
working on right now um or like how can
people follow you find you and keep
updating everything you're doing yeah
twitter jake shows aj there's jake
shields on instagram
as far as stuff pushing and there's not
really much they need to have a clothing
line i launched uh american jitsu which
is american fight.com
you know people that are interested in
fighting i have some dvds on bga
fanatics but most of my stuff i'm doing
is uh i don't really need promo for
amazing well guys please go follow jake
um he's talking about things that really
matter right now um not enough people um
are brave enough to speak up about it so
head over to um his twitter if you're
not following him already jake thank you
so much for coming on it's been so
fascinating speaking with you um and
yeah i want to thank you so much great
yeah thanks for having me i'm sure uh
we'll stay in touch and i'll see you at
some point so have a good day absolutely
all right guys thanks so much for
watching don't forget to tune in for
another episode next week and we will
see you all then
the layout show